you've all been waiting for project
Scorpio news and we've got lots of it so
let's just jump right in I'm Tony and
this is your upgraded gamespot news
update our reports come from digital
foundry and Eurogamer who witnessed a
forza motorsport demo that ran at 60
frames per second in native 4k the
console itself includes a one terabyte
hard drive and 12 gigs of gddr5 ram the
ps4 only has eight by comparison of
those 12 gigs eight are accessible to
developers while four are reserved for
system use that's a step up from the
current xbox one which reserves five
gigs for developers and just 3 for the
system and of course Scorpio also
contains a new GPU and CPU the reports
also deal with how current xbox one and
360 games will be handled on Scorpio
with a goal of running those with
dynamic scaling at their highest
possible resolution and a more stable
frame rate for all standard 1080p
displays will receive sampled down Ultra
HD rendering so games should look better
on your screen regardless additionally
game DVR has been upgraded to capture
HDR gameplay at 4k and 60fps it's all
uphill from here so be sure to like and
subscribe to keep up with all the
Scorpio news like pricing for example an
official number has not been revealed
but the same reports estimate a
five-hundred-dollar price point based on
the specs they've seen considering the
console is slated to launch this fall we
should hear something official soon for
more tech talk you can always check out
our lobby segment on how we pulled off
our awesome April Fool's Zelda prank
[Music]